there has to be a public example of what
can happen if you really cross the line
has
do you understand what i'm saying like
if there's not a public example it's
like yeah but listen
i kind of know how to work uh in between
the lines to still get my message across
and i'm having this conversation here or
there
you know like even you know the mob
right the mob is like hey we have omerta
hey and i've sat with god knows how many
people in the mob world i've interviewed
you know it's a in the mob
if you go through america you may get
killed your family may pay a price for
it so it's the price is even bigger but
the ci is not going to say if you do
anything
andy we're going to come after your your
son and your daughter and your wife and
you know they can't say that right to
you right so
what is bigger than taking your life the
garnishing wages i don't give a [ __ ] if
you garnish my way just let's just say
if i'm going through it if i'm ci that's
not that scary right the only thing
that's really that scary
is family blood and other things that i
don't get to do because you're a
professional at uh at hiding it's not
like they're putting a chip in you where
if you decide to go live in a place if
you really wanted to hide you could hide
away from cia couldn't you uh you could
try yeah we have the skills to try and
to do a pretty good job of it but if
they were to really use all of their
resources they'd find pretty much
anybody so what's been a method where
they've done something where other
people are
scared to not want to follow through
with that
so i think it's there's two things here
right so first i would say that you
don't have i would disagree with your
first point that you have to have a
public example of punishment to convince
people not to do something you actually
don't need a public punishment you just
need to state and demonstrate some level
of
high probability that something might
happen
most people are motivated by fear
fear true fear is a future state
so if they just instill enough fear fear
is something that controls behavior
so if you're coming from cia i mean matt
put yourself in the shoes of a person
who has committed part of their life to
working for this organization and then
they leave
and then they start writing a book or
they start speaking out they start
coming on podcasts whatever it might be
they don't want to
run the risk of crossing a boundary too
far and then actually forcing the hand
of the federal government you don't want
to be that person because you're in in
my heart i'm still very proud of serving
the last thing i want to do
going to jail isn't the worst thing
having my wages garnered isn't the worst
thing
losing the respect of the same
organization that i served losing the
respect of the american people who i
love
that's that's
worse than sitting in a jail cell yeah
but
that's your character that's not
everyone's character that's a lot of our
characters the people i left keep in
mind i left
i had my first child and i left
many people have many children and stay
many people sacrifice their
relationships multiple divorces they
sacrifice their health they sacrifice
their fitness they sacrifice everything
to continue to serve
for me and my wife at 2014 came and we
had to make a life decision and we
decided to prioritize family first now
you were exactly right that's 2016 on
massive attrition from the intelligence
services we were at the front end of it
but what they've seen since 2016 is
incredible
and we were at the we didn't start the
trend we just happened to be on the
first wave of leaving but you you left
like at the price it's like selling your
property at a perfect time you sold at a
perfect time and we're very happy of it
too yeah oh i mean congratulations on
selling your property at a perfect time
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]